our subject
do you know god
in the name of our lord and our savior
jesus christ
by whose grace you and i are alive right
now to listen to his word to fellowship
one with another
i'm grateful to pass to jivan for this
blessed invitation to speak for god
and to speak to his church family
at the dan harris memorial sds central
church in hyderabad india
it has been my privilege in the past to
visit india on two occasions
i spoke at spice memorial had a
delightful time
i spoke at an english church in mumbai
i spoke in hosur
and i spoke at a place called salisbury
i hope i have those names correct and on
each occasion i enjoyed myself very much
and perhaps one day if god sees fit i
will have the pleasure and the privilege
of returning physically to india the
seventh largest country on the face of
the earth and the largest democracy
i hope and pray that the words god gives
me
will make a difference in your life you
know jesus said
in john 6 63
the words that i speak unto you
they are spirit
and they are life
and this is literal the words that i
speak unto you say jesus
they are spirit
and they are life
the words of jesus are not just the
words of matthew mark luke and john
the words of jesus are the bible writing
from genesis to revelation because the
bible tells us when the old testament
prophets wrote they were led by the
spirit of christ
and the same spirit inspired the new and
so i hope and pray that the words god
has given to me
will be a blessing to your lives if
there is anyone listening to me who is
not a seventh theatricist
i am very delighted you have joined us
and i pray that the lord will bless you
and put a double blessing on your
children and that the lord will draw you
closer and closer to his bosom
and that you'll be so blessed as a
result of joining this service
that you will want to fellowship again
with the dan harris memorial sds central
church in hyderabad
again i thank pastor jivan for the
invitation and if anyone else was
associated with this invitation i thank
you
and may the lord bless you always
my subject for today
do you know god
do you know
god
before i begin i'll ask you to preserve
reverence where you are
if you're using a phone
for a bible then make sure it does not
ring so that god is not disturbed
even though we are on zoom
or facebook or youtube or whatever other
means of connection you're using
god is still god
and zoom does not make god less holy
and so preserve reference where you are
so that the lord can smile upon us
because god tells us in first samuel 2
them that honor me i will honor let's
honor god with reverence
the second favor i ask of you
is that you pray for me while i'm
speaking of course pray quietly in your
heart simply say lord
put your words
in that man's mouth
that request is based on jeremiah
chapter one
verse nine
that verse says
then the lord put forth his hand and
touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth i want to
speak god's words the devil will try to
twist my tongue but if you pray then god
will hear your prayer and he will
control my mind and my mouth and will
give me the right words to speak and the
third favor i ask i will always ask
is that you think
think
and concentrate as you listen to the
word of god
you know the pastor said open thou mine
eyes denying they behold wondrous things
out of thy law psalm 108 19 verse 18
in order for that to happen we have to
think
isaiah 1 18 tells us
come now
let us reason together set the lord god
is such a good god he is willing
to reason with us and so think as you
listen
pray for me while i'm speaking and
preserve reverence where you are our
subject
do you know god the time where i am
9 33 in the morning let's bow our heads
and pray
loving father in heaven this is a high
honor you've given to me
first
to speak for you and secondly to
fellowship with your people at the dan
harris memorial sds central church in
hyderabad
father i humble myself before you and i
ask you in the name of jesus
to use me
first for your glory
and for the blessing of your sons and
your daughters whom you love so much
if i've offended you forgive me
cleanse me to god that i might be a
thick vessel in your hands
control my mind
control my mouth control all of me
regardless so that i am simply an
instrument in your hand
speak directly through me father that
the words your people hear will really
be words from the throne of grace
bless the church family listening their
god bless the leadership a special
blessing on pastor javan
leadership is not easy god given wisdom
that you give to solomon that he may
lead your people forward
and upward
if anyone listening to me that god has
contracted the omicron or any other of
the violent variants
i'm asking you now in the name of jesus
heal those people their god
i'm asking for total healing for anyone
who has contracted the coronavirus
called 19 or any therian begin your
healing with members of the household of
faith
but even if someone listening is not a
believer because your word says he
maketh his son to rise on the evil and
on the good bless that person with
healing i pray that as you show your
goodness to that person that may draw
the person to you
wherever your seventh-day adventist
people are bless them bless every
country represented by the listening
audience they god bless the leaders of
those countries particularly the host
country of india remind them their god
that righteousness exalted the nation
and that the most high god ruleth in the
kingdom of men
nowaday god use me i pray in jesus name
amen
our subject
do you know god
let us go to the book of exodus chapter
20.
exodus is the second book of the bible
chapter 20 this is the chapter where the
ten commandments are introduced in the
fullness
exodus chapter 20
we read from verse one
our subject do you know god
the bible says and i read from the king
james version of the bible
and god speak all these words saying
i am the lord thy god
which have brought thee out of the land
of egypt
out of the house of bondage
listen now to the first commandment thou
shalt have
no other gods
before me
very first commandment
and god had a reason why he made that
commandment number one
thou shalt have no other gods
before me
whether that god is made of wood is made
of stone whether that god is a river or
a tree or a mountain whether that god is
a family member whether that god is your
career whether that god is your
education whether that god is money
whether that god is romance the bible
says thou shalt have
no
other gods
before me
which means
that god wants to be
first
in your life
our subject do you know god
the first commandment thou shalt have no
other gods before me now as i read the
words of the bible i want you to believe
that god is speaking directly to you
not to the person seated next to you on
the couch
god will take care of that person
believe that god is speaking to you
whether you're an adult or a child and
may god bless the little children who
are listening
thou shalt have no other gods before me
now let's take a look at this person who
says thou shalt have no other gods
before me what gives him the right to
say that
let us go to the book of isaiah
isaiah
chapter 40 we read from verse 25
chapter 40 four zero reading from verse
25 the book of isaiah is called the
gospel prophet because isaiah writes so
much about jesus and the ministry christ
came to fulfill
isaiah chapter 40 reading from verse 25
let me pray again father continue to
control my mind and my mouth in jesus
name i pray amen the bible says to whom
then will ye liken me
or shall i be equal saith the holy one
god is saying who on this earth or
anywhere in heaven is like i am to whom
will he liken me to whom will you
compare me says god
then he tells us in verse 26
lift up your eyes on high and behold who
hath created these things that bringeth
out their hosts by number he calleth
them all by names by the greatness of
his might for that he is strong in power
not one of them fearless now god is
saying look
there is no one like me and the reason
for that is i am the one who created and
so he tells us look up
he could have said look around because
he made heaven on earth he said look up
and when you look up and you see the
stars and you see the sun and you see
the heavenly bodies you will realize
that some special power created heaven
and that power that's me says god and
there is no one else like me
you cannot contain me says god to anyone
else
remember our subject do you know god
in the book of psalms let's go to psalms
we'll read verse 5.
psalm
reading verse 5. listen very carefully
to what that verse says
i hope you have it by now for all the i
all the gods of the nations are idols
but the lord made the heavens here again
god is telling us that he is different
from all of the gods why because he
made the heavens and the earth he is the
creator let us go to jeremiah chapter 10
we read from verse 11 of jeremiah 10.
jeremiah chapter 10 reading from verse
11 our subject do you know god and we're
talking about the god who said
thou shalt have no other gods before me
if god wants me to obey that what is so
special about god that he should be
first in my life jeremiah chapter 10
reading verse 11 thus shall he say unto
them the gods that have not made the
heavens and the earth even they shall
perish from the earth and from under
these heavens here again we have god
distinguishing himself from all of the
false gods listen carefully to jeremiah
10 11 thus shall he say to them the gods
that have not made the heavens and the
earth even they shall perish from the
earth and from under these heavens in
other words god is saying i
am the creator of heaven and earth and
that is what makes me different from all
other so called gods
we've established that god tells us
in his word there is no other god like
me let's add one more verse to that
isaiah 45 let's go to verse 18.
isaiah 45
reading verse 18
our subject do you know god i'm reading
from the king james version of the bible
and i hope someone has already said lord
put your words in that man's mouth
isaiah
chapter 45 verse 18. the bible said for
thus said the lord that created the
heavens
god himself that formed the earth and
made it he has established it he created
it not in vain he formed it to be
inhabited now notice how that verse ends
i am the lord and there's none else
there's no one else like me and why is
that because he created heaven and earth
creation
is what separates god from all other
so-called gods
having established that god is different
from all of the gods he cannot be
compared to anyone else let us learn
something else about god who created
heaven on earth
we will go to the new testament the book
of acts we have matthew mark luke john
then x chapter 7
we'll read from verse 47.
the book of acts written by luke by the
way luke tolbert he wrote the gospel of
luke and he wrote the book of acts
acts chapter 7
reading from verse 47 our subject do you
know god
we read and i hope you follow me
carefully
but solomon built him a house
solomon built a house for god how be it
verse 48
the most high dwelleth not in temples
made with hands as said the prophet
verse 49
heaven is my throne
and earth is my footstool what house
will he build me save the lord or what
is the place of my rest now the bible is
saying you cannot put god in a building
he is too big and we'll get to the size
of god the bible tells us so the book of
acts tells us
what house will he now this is god
speaking to solomon
what house will he build me you cannot
put me in a house it was god who
instructed david and solomon to build
the temple but he wants us to understand
you cannot put the creator in a house
and tell him that's where he lives
notice what verse 49 says heaven
is my throne
all of heaven is as if god sits on
heaven
and no one can measure the size of
emerald earth is my footstool what does
that mean in some houses people have
couches and the couch has a little story
place your foot god is saying the earth
is my footstool i put my foot on the
earth and rested i sit on the heavens
how can you put me in a house
the most high
dwelleth not in temples made with man's
hands you cannot enclose god in a
building we have buildings called
churches but that's not where god lives
that's not where god dwelt that's where
his children go to worship him
to the book of first kings chapter 8
let's read verse 27
first kings chapter 8 reading verse 27
first kings
chapter 8
reading verse 27
but will god indeed dwell on the earth
behold the heaven and the heaven of
heavens cannot contain him
how much less this house that i have
built it solomon is saying look
i've built a temple for god but this
temple cannot contain god listen to the
verse again but will god indeed dwell on
the earth
behold the heaven and the heaven of
heavens
what is that expression the heaven and
the heaven of heavens cannot contain him
in other words god in a way we do not
understand is bigger than the entire
universe
and i cause for you to think about that
notice i said in a way we cannot
understand because we tend to think the
largest thing in existence is the
universe
the bible tells us the universe as large
as it is cannot contain god
that kind of statement must simply
detain by faith because we cannot grasp
let me tell you a little about the
universe very little
we live in what is called the milky way
that's our galaxy and a galaxy is a
collection of stars and planets and dust
and whatever other you know
intel uh material we have in space a
galaxy
our galaxy is called the milky way and
the scientists tell us the uh
astronomers astronomers that they are
billions of galaxies ours is the milky
way
how large is the milky way
according to the experts
if you travel at the speed of light
which is 300 000 kilometers a second
let me say that again for those of you
who use different system that's 186 000
miles an hour
300 000 kilometers
[Music]
a second
approximately
it would take you
000 years just across the milky way our
galaxy that's just one galaxy
000 years to cross the milky way galaxy
traveling at the speed of light that is
huge but let's reduce it to sizes you
and i can understand
as we continue with
do you know god
if you drove a car
at about a hundred kilometers per hour
without ever stopping
it would take you six months to reach
the moon
and the moon is just on our doorstep
if you drove a car
100 kilometers an hour
without ever stopping for food or gas or
anything else
it would take you
six months of constant driving to reach
the moon
if you drove a car
at 100 kilometers per hour without ever
stopping
it would take you 17 years of continual
uninterrupted driving to reach the sun
that's far
if you had to drive from
the southern part of india
to punjab you would probably put your
head in your hand and say that is too
far if you had to walk it you probably
say i prefer to die
to you that's far
17 years of driving at 100 kilometers
per hour to reach the moon now this is
just the sun and the moon and within
context of the universe they are just
next door
the bible says
god is bigger than the universe
don't try to explain it just accept it
read the verse again first kings 8 27
but will god indeed dwell on the earth
the earth is too small
behold the heaven and heaven of heavens
cannot contain him
much less this house that i have built
it this is the god who says to us to
whom then will he like me
or shall i be equal
the god who says to us
thou shalt have no other gods before me
is a god who is so big
he is bigger
than the universe i cannot explain that
the bible says it i accept it by faith
now
having said all of that
let's take another look at this god
this big god
let us go who does not live in buildings
who cannot be contained in buildings not
even the universe can contain him let's
look at something that seems to be the
very opposite
let me pray again
loving father in heaven
tell me what to say
that your people might be enlightened
and blessed in jesus name i pray
amen
go with me to second corinthians 6 we'll
read from verse 14
our subject do you know god
second corinthians 6
we'll read from verse 14.
i'll give you a few seconds to find that
passage
second corinthians written by the
apostle paul
chapter 6
reading verse from verse 14 i hope i
said 14 from verse 14 we go down to 16.
the bible says be not an equally yoked
together with unbelievers
for what fellowship
has righteousness with unrighteousness
and what communion has light with
darkness
and what concord hath christ with belial
or what part as a believer with an
infidel or what what agreement have the
temple of god with idols
for ye are the temple of the living god
as god has said i will dwell in them and
walk in them now let me pause god has
said i will dwell in them
that's you
and that's me
do you catch the difficulty perhaps
difficult is not the word we established
from the bible first kings 8 27
acts 7 47 to 49
the earth a temple the universe is too
small for god god is bigger than the
universe bigger than a church building
bigger than the earth he is just big yet
which is red where god said
i
will dwell in them
now how do you explain that but it is a
reality why because the bible does not
lie the god that is so big
that the universe cannot contain him
first kings 8 27
the god who is so big that no church
building can contain him acts 7 verse 47
48 49 the god who is so powerful that he
made the universe and if he made the
universe he has to be bigger than the
universe or more powerful than the
universe this same god
as massive and as big as he is he wants
to dwell in you
how do you explain that you cannot you
simply say thank you
that a god
for whom the universe is too small
desires to dwell in us
let's review what we've learned about
god one
goddess told us clearly his very first
commandment now the bible tells us all
the bible was inspired by the holy
spirit and so the holy spirit led the
writer of exodus to put commandment one
as it is thou shalt have no other gods
before me we've learned from god that he
does not want any other god ahead of him
in your life
two
we've learned from god that there is no
one with whom he can be compared isaiah
40 25 and 26 we've learned that he
cannot be compared with anyone else
there's none like him isaiah 45 verse
18. there's none like him jeremiah 10 11
there's none like him isaiah 45 22
isaiah 46 9 and 10 there is no other
like god this big god who is bigger than
the universe
now to our astonishment
we have learned that this
big god
will find a way if you and i will allow
him to dwell in us
let us go back to second corinthians 6
let's read 14 to 16 again because this
is an amazing statement because of what
we just found out about god second
corinthians 6 14 to 16 be not been
equally yoked together with unbelievers
for what fellowship have righteousness
with unrighteousness
and what communion has light with
darkness
and what concord hath christ with belial
or what part has a believer with an
infidel or what agreement and what
agreement has the temple of god with
idols for ye are the temple of the
living god
we know from acts 8 7 47-48
god does not live in temples because the
bible says in verse 47 of acts 7
solomon built him a house verse 48 how
be it the most high dwelleth not in
temples made with hands
god does not dwell in temples yet we
read in second corinthians 6
16 ye are the temple of the living god
it is an amazing thing to contemplate
but since god does not lie numbers 23 19
titus chapter 1 verse 2 he does not lie
and he
finds a way
a god who is bigger than the universe
finds a way to dwell in you and to dwell
in me an amazing consideration
but it also tells us something about god
god is a very personal
and intimate god
as big as he is
he wants to have a personal relationship
with you that's you
that's god and he dwells in you
i cannot explain the details of how he
dwells in you a god so big how do you
fit a bus into a a purse i cannot
explain it but if god says he does it he
will do it because the bible says with
god nothing shall be impossible luke
chapter 1 verse 37 god said to abraham
in genesis 18 verse 14 is anything
through hearts of the lord the answer is
no therefore a god who is bigger than
the universe will and does find a way to
dwell in you i am saying to you my
listening brother and sister
god who created heaven and earth
god who is bigger than the universe
god who cannot be compared to anyone
else or anything else she
wants to dwell within you
can you think of a greater privilege
if the
the leader of the nation of india wanted
to come to your house
you would be privileged beyond
description you will be excited you tell
all your family members that the the
leader of this of india is coming to my
house i will sit at my table and will
dine with me i will sit at my chair and
will talk with me and drink with me you
will tell the whole world now the god of
the universe
see india is the seventh largest country
the universe is the largest place
god is larger than that and he wants to
dwell in you
with your permission
let me say it again with your permission
let's look at something else about this
god we know that he wants to be first in
our lives thou shalt have no other gods
before me we know he cannot be compared
to any other soul and i keep saying so
called god because he's really is the
only god we know that he is so big he
cannot be contained in a building the
bible says not even the universe can
contain god we know from the bible he
wants to dwell in you and in me let's
find out something else about this god
the most popular verse in the bible john
verse 16. you can say it without looking
for god so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have everlasting life
this god
who tells us have no gods before me
this god who tells us you cannot compare
me to any other god
this god who is so big that the universe
cannot contain him
this god who despite his bigness wants
to dwell in you
this god who created heaven and earth
this god wants to say to you
now let's reason together before we do
let me pray again father as i continue
speaking to your beautiful blessed
people talk to me and talk through me
father please in jesus name i pray amen
let me ask you this question
which is a bigger task for god
making the entire universe
or solving a problem in your individual
life which is bigger for god here is
this god who is bigger than the universe
can he solve the problems in your life
the answer is yes
second question does he want to solve
the problems the answer is yes
can he save you the answer is yes why
because he's the powerful god who is
bigger than the universe he's the god
who gives you life the breath you're
taking right now is the result of the
working of god in your life the direct
working of god in your life you do not
breathe in and out because of some
independent working of the law of
physics and physiology and
a high concentration of gas moves
towards the law area of concentration
not only wrong you and i are alive
because of the conscious working of god
the bible tells us
in him we live
and move
and have our being
perhaps where you are there's a plant in
your house or there's a tree in your
yard
that plant that tree
is alive by the power of this big god
who is bigger than the universe but who
is so concerned about little things he
keeps a tree alive he keeps the grass
alive and he keeps you alive
this big god
cares about you
and he says to you in john 3 16
i want to save you
you from what
from sin
is god able to do that yes
does he want to do that yes
i'll tell you something else about this
god
god loves you
in a way
that is
self-sacrificial
which is the only way to love what do i
mean by that
let us go to john john
chapter 15 john 15
we read from verse 12 our subject do you
know god
john chapter 15 reading from verse 12.
where i am is one minute after 10 in the
morning i won't hold you very long but i
want a few more minutes to complete this
message
john 15 reading from verse 12 this
gospel of john was written by the
disciple who was closer to christ than
any of the other 11. this is john by the
way he also wrote the book of revelation
and he wrote first second and third john
here's what you write john 15 verse 12
this is my commandment
that you love one another
not a suggestion by the way i'm talking
to a church
god does not suggest that you love your
fellow church member he commands you
it has nothing to do with whether you
feel like loving the person god's
commandments are to be obeyed not based
on feeling but because he said so and we
love him when the bible says thou shalt
not kill it is not concerned with how
you feel
don't kill when the bible says thou
shalt not steal feeling has nothing to
do with it don't steal and so the bible
says this is my commandment
not suggestion not recommendation that
you love one another by the way if
there's someone in the church you don't
love ask god to help you to love that
person so that you might obey god all
right let's finish the quotation
this is my commandment that you love one
another as i have loved you
now listen to verse 13.
greater love hath no man than this
that a man
lay down his life
for his friends
i pause
listen to this verse
microscopically
greater love have no man or no one on
earth or there's no one anywhere in the
universe who can express a greater love
than the love which is expressed in
self-sacrifice greater love have no man
than this that a man lay down his life
for his friends the giving up of the
life is the greatest expression of love
we're getting to know god our subject is
do you know god
if this is the case
and the bible says it is
the bible also says in first john
chapter 4 verse 8 let's go here first
john chapter 4 verse 8 our subject do
you know god
first john chapter 4 verse 8.
we all know this verse very well here's
what it says
he that loveth not
knoweth not god
for god is
love god
is love
which is more powerful than saying god
has love god is love now listen to what
the bible says about love in john 15 13
greater love had no man than this that a
man lay down his life for his friends
now if a human being
can express that kind of love what level
of love can god express no human being
no created being can love more than god
i want you to follow me closely because
what i want to say is astonishing
love
according to john 3 16 for god so loved
the world that he gave
his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have everlasting life
when god gave his son jesus
in jesus god gave himself
because the greatest expression of love
is not to have someone else die is for
you to die for someone else let me say
that again the bible says the greatest
expression of love is for someone to die
for someone else what i'm telling you
god gave himself for you when he gave
jesus christ
that's why the bible says god was in
christ
reconciling the world unto himself
second corinthians 5 19 god was
in christ
now i cannot explain all the details
because the gospel is a divine creation
no human being can fully understand it
that is why in the new world it will be
our study for all eternity
but listen to me again
god tells us in the mouth of jesus
greater love have no man than this that
a man lay down his life for his friends
if god said it he has to do it
in christ
god gave himself for us
what does that mean
we learned from first kings 8 29 the
universe is too small to contain god
this big god
gave himself for us when he gave jesus
christ
this big god by giving himself he
sacrificed everything
that salvation might be made available
to you and to me do you know god
let's review
then i have something to tell you at the
end
god tells you and me have no other god
before me
god tells you and me you cannot compare
me to anyone
god tells you and me
i am too big to be housed the universe
is too small to continue
which means god is outside the universe
and we can understand that
god says to you and me even though i am
so big i want to dwell inside you
god tells you and me this big god that i
am i want to save you i can save you
because i am the greatest power in the
universe
when you think of all of that
listen to what i'm about to say to you
god owes you and me
nothing
he wants to give us
everything
you see god made the heavens god made
the earth
god made animals god made trees god made
birds he made a dry land he made the
seed he made everything he made humanity
god owes us nothing
we or him everything
this god
wants to save you
this big god
this all-powerful god wants to dwell
in you
and you ask me how does that happen
and i said you very simply you say to
god
father
come and dwell within me
i need you
i cannot save myself
i cannot safely guide my life
i need a power from without
that power is you and the only power
that can sus that can suffice to guide
me securely the only power that can lead
me from this path all the way to the
kingdom of god when he comes is the very
presence of god
you simply say to god
father
to whatever degree i understand i ask
you to come into my life
you the big god too big for the universe
come into my life you say that with all
your heart
and this god
that the universe cannot contain
will find a way
to dwell in your heart because the bible
says in second corinthians 6 16 ye are
the temple of the living god not that
building where you go
yes it is set aside to worship god but
god's preferred dwelling place is within
you you are his temple and he finds a
way to inhabit you and from within
he directs your life not from without
god does not direct your life from the
bible
on your shelf
in your living room or in your bedroom
he directs your life from within
and he directs you and me
do you know god my listening friend i am
inviting you in the name of jesus
give your life
to this god
repetition is an effective tool of
teaching
give your life to this god
who is bigger than the earth
the universe than a mountain than a
building that a tree then an animal give
your life to this god who says i made
heaven on earth and there is no other
god beside me
he loves you
personally
i have to say that again this big god
loves little you and little me
personally
that's where god begins
at the personal level
the second level is a social level
god begins at the personal level if you
go to the book of luke chapter 15 we
have the parable of the lord sheep and
then i'll close
let me pray again father continue to be
with me please i pray as i close this
message in jesus name amen we begin from
verse three onward what man of you you
know jesus made this parable saying what
matter of you having a hundred sheep one
hundred
if he lose
one
does not leave the mighty and i in the
wilderness and go after that which is
lost until he find it observe what jesus
says and christ is the shepherd and the
good shepherd
john 10 7
he's referring to himself and his
father
i am a shep
100 sheep
every person on the earth
if one goes astray
i leave the 99 and i go after that lost
one
by myself
so that when i find that lost sheep it
is just the sheep and the shepherd no
one else what does that teach us god
desires a personal private relationship
with you where no one else is invited
now in your society
and most in all societies
the group is important i understand that
don't misunderstand but i said god
begins
with the individual
then he goes to the group level he made
adam first then he made it then he
brought them together so he got
individuals and made them a society
god wants a relationship with you
you
forget everyone else in india or
whatever country you're in he wants a
relationship with you
and he's inviting you right now
to have that relationship with him come
come come you know in matthew 11 28
jesus says come to me
all you that labor come to me because
this god is a person this god loves this
god gets angry this god is sad this god
blesses god can be happy god is an
intelligent being god is not electricity
god is not a force he is a person we do
not fully understand him he is a person
that we know from the bible that he
loves he's jealous he blesses he gets
angry he punishes he forgives he's long
suffering we know all of that
this
massive big intelligent god
wants to dwell within you invite him
right where you are by simply saying
whether your child or an adult because
god loves little children to say to him
come into my life because the sooner god
comes into your life the more secure
your life is
the devil also wants you as an early age
but give your life to god the god of the
universe simply say lord come into my
life
and direct me and say that every day
if i close
there is a god
who is bigger than the universe
first kings 8 27.
there is a god who tells you and me
don't put anyone ahead of me
exodus 20 verse 3.
there is a god that tells you you cannot
compare me to anyone else
isaiah 40 25 26
there is a god that says what makes me
different from all of the gods i created
heaven and earth jeremiah 10 verse 11
psalm 96 verse 5. there is a god that
says you cannot house me in a building
acts 7 47 to 50.
there's a god that says i want to save
you
john 3 16 there's a god that says i want
to dwell in you personally second
corinthians 6 16
say yes to this god
i say it one more time by simply saying
father
come into my life
and direct my life
i give you permission 100
come into my life
you the big god
find a way to come into my little heart
and direct my life heath bow eyes close
father in heaven we thank you for your
word
we thank you for god for the simplicity
of the word if we will read it honestly
i thank you for those who listen in the
name of jesus christ their god
clarify my weak words so that the
message becomes even clearer as your
people now reflect on what they've heard
open their eyes they've got to see and
to understand that this great god you
want to have a personal relationship
with them you the god bigger than the
universe desire to dwell in their hearts
bless them be god
in a certain way wrap your arms around
them individually and as a group
buying them to your father
and save them all when you come
again i ask you to pour out a special
blessing on anyone listening who is not
a seventh-day adventist touch that
person heal that person provide that
person's need save those persons their
god
anyone listening who has coveted 19 heal
those persons father and bless the
governments of the countries represented
by those listening
but father in a very special way
president harris memorial sda central
church in hyderabad and pour out a
blessing upon india de god
let the church in india spread its
message far and wide
that multiplied thousands will be ready
to meet christ when he comes
hear this humble prayer
give me the message for your people
tomorrow
keep us alive until that time i pray
in jesus name
amen
you